hi it's matthew Martin eight details and  I just saw the Bottega Vanetta show  which I loved it was all about a neo  Bowie glam rock moment the silhouettes  were super streamlined really sexy there  was a bunch of great suiting that had  really cool shadow printing some of it  had anthracite printing on it which is  really interesting in modern the denim  was amazing it was all super sleek and  straight and dark very good motocross  pieces bunch of wonderful shearling  jackets there was definitely a stacked  heel boot which you know may not be for  every guy but I was feeling it if you  notice there was no bags in the  collection and I think that was to go  with the really streamlined silhouette  as usual like Thomas gave us a really  masculine interpretation of how the  modern man should dress follow me on  twitter at details Matt and check out  details calm for more shows in Milan and  Paris throughout the week